[Música]
buenos días
entre 1980 y 1983 costa rica vivió la
peor crisis económica desde la segunda
guerra mundial imagínense lo que es una
inflación del 105 por ciento hoy tenemos
un 34 por ciento nuestros salarios
cayeron un 40 por ciento su poder
adquisitivo en esa época yo tenía 23 24
años para cálculo y me da
y había terminado mis estudios de
seguridad civil
pero no había trabajo
era una situación muy complicada y como
pueden ver
subió largas en 86 por ciento la
medicina 200 por ciento con una tremenda
crisis
eso me me llevó a que tuve que
reinventar me que sucedió el gobierno de
monje que fue que seguida después decide
como una medida para reactivar la
economía bajar los impuestos de las
computadoras que en aquella época pagaba
un 130 por ciento y luego al 10%
impuestos de ventas esto genera un boom
yo sin trabajo veo que unas
multinacionales empiezan a abrir becas o
pasantías para llevar jóvenes
profesionales que conozcan del tema
estoy en la beca estoy estudiando
tecnología aprendiendo el día a día del
negocio de esa área y veo que en la
calle todo mundo estaba comprando
computadoras y yo con 25 años soltero y
sin compromisos digo yo porque pierdo
voy a aprovechar esto que está
sucediendo y voy a crear una empresa eso
fue hace 34 años y hoy más de 130 y pico
de familias vivimos de un sueño de un
cambio lo que parecía una barrera se
convirtió en una oportunidad entonces he
sido un fiel creyente de las pasantías
porque una pasantía como les decía me
dio una oportunidad
muchas empresas igual que la que yo
represento aquí hemos estado dando
pasantías por muchos años tal vez sin
reglas claras y yo tengo el caso de rock
n roll fue muchacho que el papá se me
acerca y me dice mira julio yo no puedo
pagar los estudios universitarios de mi
hijo y él terminó el colegio pero qué
hago y
en tecnología siempre hay oportunidades
hay unas becas que están ofreciendo que
aplica la beca y si eres tan bueno como
usted me dice que venga a trabajar con
nosotros después y yo le ofrezco igual
una oportunidad
róger con un pequeño testimonio de él a
ver si lo podemos poner a correr
y
por eso
el mundo
y
en la parte de abajo
cuando la información
regalo
y nadie
bueno por róger estuvo cuatro años con
nosotros y una multinacional se lo ha
llevado ganando mucha plata y el saco a
su familia adelante tuvo una oportunidad
y lo ha logrado bueno pero a veces como
país no aprendemos 40 años prácticamente
después estamos en una nueva crisis y
tenemos un serio problema con el déficit
fiscal pero a mí lo que en la uccaep que
nosotros como cámara comercio hemos
parte local lo que más nos tiene ocupado
de la siguiente estadística para nos
hace una encuesta resulta que él
30% de los jóvenes entre 16 y 25 años
que casi todos están esa en esa
población verdad no consiguen trabajo y
lo más ocupante es que cuando van a
buscar trabajo el 59% de las empresas
pide experiencia entonces se complica
más bueno gracias a ellos recientemente
hace unas pocas semanas el gobierno
presentó el proyecto de educación dual y
fue aprobado en la asamblea legislativa
en un trabajo conjunto con la
institución educativa con el colegio o
universidad y la empresa privada ahora
sí tenemos reglas claras para que los
muchachos realmente puedan dar provecho
de una pasantía y puedan empezar a ganar
la experiencia que se requiere para
conseguir un trabajo entonces eso es una
muy buena noticia que tienen ustedes
como una oportunidad como la tuve yo
hace 34 años y que cambió mi vida
pero bueno
porque le puse educación trial porque
realmente el saber realmente ustedes
ahora tienen dos oportunidades una es
irse por certificaciones como el eso
roger o buscar su carrera universitaria
eso depende mucho la situación que tenga
cada uno de su familia
con la carrera con las becas o con con
las pasantías y están dando ustedes
pueden como luis rogel poder empezar a
obtener el dinero o traer por lo menos
un sustento a sus hogares o por una
carrera universitaria posteriormente
robert que es lo que hizo fue terminó su
su beca trabajó con nosotros y se auto
financió su carrera universitaria pero
bueno como les decía
tenemos tres pilares y es la parte de
educación trial el primero
esa educación el segundo es trabajo y el
tercero que es importantísimo y por eso
les decía el nombre educación trial es
los valores
yo quiero hoy por tiempo darles tres
principios que me han ayudado mucho
durante todo estos 24 años de cambiar
empresarial y quiero compartir se los en
el tiempo que me queda el primero es una
ley que siempre se cumple que se llama
la ley de la siembra y la cosecha y es
muy fácil en agricultura
si yo siempre una semilla mangos que voy
a cosechar
mangos semillas naranjas naranjas no hay
forma eso se cumple pues igual se cumple
con los valores
si usted siempre ha veracidad si usted
es una persona con la que puedo en la
que creo usted va a tener muy buena
reputación y la reputación vale
si usted es leal una persona leal una
persona que también se pueda confiar
usted va a tener relaciones fuertes
si usted
es dirigente es una persona proactiva
usted va a ser una persona que va tiene
siempre promoción la hora y lo van a
buscar ese fue el caso de lógica si
usted tiene dominio propio usted desea
evitar muchos problemas porque vivir en
un ambiente más seguro
si usted trabaja duro va a tener éxito
hablaba en el tema del estudio si
estudian y van a tener éxito hay que
estudiar duro y continuamente ya nos
acaba a los 15 25 30
hay que estudiar toda la vida
y si usted siembra
[Música]
perdón va a tener salud entonces hay una
hay una frase que es la que a mí me
encanta que es que es el carácter de una
persona el carácter de una persona es
que hace usted cuando ahí lo está viendo
piensen en eso el segundo principio que
quería compartirles es
el talento te abre muchas puertas pero
el ser amable y agradecido se las
mantiene abiertas nunca olviden eso
todos aquí son talentosos pero la vida
da muchas vueltas y como ustedes hayan
sido en un momento que tuvieron también
un muy buen trabajo estuvieron
empoderados como hayan tratado a los
demás esto les va a abrir observar
puertas entonces nunca se olviden de ese
principio gay aprovechen el talento que
tienen pero sean amables y agradecidos
siempre y el tercero que les quiero
compartir es la filosofía de 10 pesos de
amazon que se llama día 1 que días hoy
día 1 para que para innovar para crear
una mejor empresa para ver cómo hay una
mejor experiencia al cliente como puedo
como decía también el tema hacia la
sociedad cómo puedo proyectar me y ser
más responsable con la sociedad que me
estoy desenvolviendo es ese es una
enseñanza y diez besos que es que se ha
transmitido y ha hecho lo que es amazon
hoy líder en innovación y ahí vienen que
días mañana
día 1 nuevamente qué días mañana
nuevamente día 1 qué voy a hacer hoy qué
voy a hacer hoy diferente para encantar
a mis clientes qué voy a hacer hoy
diferente para mejorar mi trabajo y
pasado mañana
día 1 entonces es la única manera de
romper esa zona de confort y la
educación continua es eso hoy es día 1 y
mañana día 1 y pasado mañana día 1 no
olviden eso este yo quería decirles que
aquí tenemos un ejemplo a nivel personal
que es quién es el el tipo más conocido
en el mundo
deportista keylor navas dígame una cosa
que lo navas
a que lo navas no cumple la ley de la
siembra de la cosecha que la nava no
tiene perdón con los que hicieron el
madrid y siguió ahí y que a que llegó
kellermann nada no tiene dominio propio
keylor navas no trabaja duro
pero nava cumple con todos los valores
pero navas no tiene talento el más
talentoso de varios fútbol que hemos
tenido y no ha mantenido todas las
puertas abiertas así lo ha hecho y vive
en el día uno todos los entrenadores de
que los dicen él trabaja al 100% todos
los días entonces llévense esto por
favor
y día a día tenemos que ser mejores
personas tenemos que luchar porque bueno
había uno más que hablaba de que yo
puedo tener barreras pero todas las
palabras se convierten en oportunidades
así que bueno muchas gracias
[Aplausos]